Kentucky senator and ophthalmologist
Rand Paul is known as one of the more
kind of strictly libertarian members of
the US Senate and one of his I call it
one of his greatest hits in terms of
just saying wacky things was when he
said that single-payer health care is
effectively slavery that it makes
doctors slaves that it makes nurses
slaves everybody's a slave when you have
single-payer health care and we've now
learned he's going to be going to health
care slavery headquarters Canada for a
hernia operation you can't write this
stuff so I want to take this piece by
piece with you let me set it up first
here's Rand Paul with his now infamous
claim that single-payer health care is a
form of slavery thank you very much
with regard to the idea of whether or
not you have a right to a health care
you have to realize what that implies
it's not an abstraction I'm a physician
that means you have a right to come to
my house and can script me means you
believe in slavery it means that you're
going to enslave not only me but the
janitor at my hospital the person who
cleans my office the assistants who work
in my office the nurses if you have a
right to their services basically once
you imply a belief in a right to someone
services you have a right to plumbing so
there it is everyone is a slave in a
single-payer health care system
according to Rand Paul if you have
single-payer health care everybody
involved in the system is condemned to a
lifetime of slavery and I'm assuming
that when he says that when he makes
that critique he believes slavery is bad
so that he wouldn't want to be
participating in such a sick system
except that Senator Rand Paul is now
opting to go to Canada for hernia
surgery remember that incident that took
place where Rand Paul was I guess raking
leaves on his front lawn and a neighbor
who I believe was an anesthesiologist
tackled him and Rand Paul ended up with
six broken ribs and a bruised lung and
apparently this hernia resulted from the
incident as well or from the recovery
from the incident so we have this market
system which I guess he believes is
great in the United States socialized
medicine is bad Canadians are being put
on horrible waiting lists for
non-emergency procedures but
turns out that shul D sore shoulders I'm
not exactly sure how it's pronounced
hernia Hospital in Ontario is a really
good place to have hernia repair done
and that's where Rand Paul is going to
go
now I'm gonna anticipate already what
the defenders of Rand Paul are going to
say they will write in and say David
hold on I am opposed to the socialized
medicine system like Rand Paul but this
particular hospital that Rand Paul is
going to is a private hospital not a
public hospital that is true by the
letter but most of the money of this
clinic comes from the government they
accept the socialized health care plan
they're doing just fine no slaves no
problems one of the best places in the
world to have hernia repair done and
it's a perfectly reasonable model you
don't need to have the government be the
healthcare provider and the employer of
the doctors and the employer of the
nurses you still can have private
hospitals but you have one pair which is
the government which provides a system
of nonprofit health insurance period
just because the provider is private as
is the case here understand that it's
mostly a publicly funded provider and
that's a model that's very popular in
the single-payer world and what we have
in the end is Rand Paul choosing because
of the quality of care at a mostly
publicly funded health clinic in health
care slavery a hub Canada he is taking
his tax payer salary out of the United
States and to a different country and I
was thinking pat on the one hand there's
this kind of hypocrisy or double
standard in another sense this is sort
of libertarianism as intended by them
he's rich and powerful so he can go to
Canada and get better at better care
other people can't even afford the
flight to Canada
never mind paying for the care as a non
citizen so they end up with the care
that happens to be available to them
with their terrible health insurance in
the part of the country where they
happen to live it's both an incredible
double standard but a version of
libertarianism that a lot of people like
Rand Paul actually support I really just
can't get over how dumb the argument is
that if you
you are for single-payer health care
you're for slavery like doctors are
compensated a good deal of money they
make six-figure salaries they don't have
to be in that position if they don't
want to the free to go you can't say the
same thing about slaves and if you're
gonna make this slavery argument when it
comes to the universal health care you
have to make it when it comes to any
public official like Rand Paul as a
politician he's a slave too apparently
we will see what other follow up there
is from Rand Paul here and it'll
probably just kind of fade away like
many of these stories do it's just our
elected officials being hypocritical
that that sadly is not actually news if
you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video